he's an American rapper record producer
actor and entrepreneur he's won two
Grammy Awards and two MTV Music Video
Awards in 2015 Forbes estimated his net
worth to be 735 million dollars he Sean
Combs and here are his top 10 rules for
success a lot of people have asked me
that how do I get to this where I'm at
it's my belief I believe so strong so
crazy so I believe to believe the power
and belief what do you believe in the
most God I believe in God rules and
after that myself
talk about the doubt you've had in
yourself you're human
no never doubted myself I go into
ignored I'm one of the baddest mother
you know not an even in a cocky way I
just feel like I'm one of the baddest
mother to ever walk the face of the
earth you know and that's just how I am
cuz I feel I am I am one badass mother
walks face with her that's just a fact
that's just a pure of fact I mean you're
one of the most important things is that
day I would say my advice is for people
to kind of um kind of ramp it up because
a lot of times when you're young and you
and your 20s or something you like I
don't really know what I want to do but
we live in a different world it's
important for you to know what you want
to do for it for the future your family
so it's a scary thing to make that
decision this is what I want to do but
the sooner you make that decision I
think the better to be for your life you
know and a better chance of success you
have because you'll have more time to
mess up have more time to fall down I
loved what I was doing I decided what I
was going to do a job I loved what I was
doing I would walk around I would dance
and sing as I was delivering my papers
and that kind of helped me to for the
future of what I wanted to do and that
was just being a young entrepreneur I
thank God every day that I'm blessed
with the chance to to do something that
I love doing but I feel anybody can do
something that that they love doing if
they if they go after it in the right
way if they go after with the love the
motivation for it is the love and the
love of leaving a legacy behind more
than the selfishness of just doing it
for money doing it to blow up to beat a
man or a woman but I have the fame if
you do it to make history if you do it
to change people's lives to make people
feel good to make yourself feel good
it's going to come it's just gonna come
naturally no we got let's go we got
don't stop we got let's get it all of
the positive terms to keep us focused
people some grind and keep us moving
keep us following chasing catching our
dreams locked in let's lock in lock in
on your dream locked in if I was coming
today I would do whatever it would take
for me to get to information I think
that no matter what it could have been
in times of Jesus before Jesus caveman
times it was about being around
information back in caveman times it was
about who knows how to make a fire cuz
my ass is cold and I'm saying and now
it's like you know who really knows who
is successful in this day and age and
how they are successful so I think that
I think that our educational system
needs to be fixed in a sense because um
you know a degree means something to me
but experience kind of means more and a
point of view of where people want to go
kind of me more than somebody and I have
a master's from Harvard or what know I
need to know are you ready to go to war
with me right that's what I need to know
you cannot achieve success without
failure some of my biggest successes
come from some of my biggest failures in
the early 90s when my friends were
graduating from Howard I got fired from
that first job that I got with Andra her
L I know a lot of you know this story
but some of you may not know how scared
I was
see I was scared to death I didn't have
a degree
my girlfriend was eight-and-a-half
months pregnant with my first baby I
bought a brand new house in Scarsdale
that I could not afford so I I found
myself sitting alone in my bedroom and
asking myself the question that
sometimes we all ask each other what are
you going to do now what are you gonna
do now you should have kept your mouth
shut
and Sun up and just do it Andre told you
to do what you wonder a Clank you was
making the hit rankings and then now
look at you what are you gonna do now so
I had two choices either I was gonna sit
in that failure and give up or I was
going to make a decision to step out of
the darkness you see when you're in that
darkness you want to sit there and wait
for the light to come when you're in
that darkness it feels uncomfortable but
you can't wait and sit in that darkness
the only way out is to step forward to
face your fears to become your own light
I had to make a decision I had to decide
to become my own life I had to believe
in myself like never before
I had to find my inner power now I'm not
gonna lie to you there's gonna be a lot
of times all about to fail I'm still
failing every day where we are all a
work in progress and one day you'll be
sitting in the dark like I was and
you're gonna be asking yourself what am
I going to do now do you ask yourself
you're getting slower down what am I
gonna do now but in that moment I want
you to remember the power of you one of
the things that I wanted to make sure
that I also answered you asked me a
question earlier about fearlessness yeah
I remember you asked me this before um
when we were doing something cans and
you know I told you have to be fearless
you know you can't be afraid of anything
right and then I you know um
the doing this cable network it's
probably I mean it's not probably it's
the hardest thing that I've ever done
second to running a marathon because I
almost died running a marathon so I have
a marathon beside Sunday take a cup so
oh and I'll tell you that story another
time when you're having doubts but um
you know so I'm in my office you know
that couple of months ago and you know
fear overcame me yeah and and I
remembered that you know I'm fearless in
a sense but having some sort of fear as
a part of fearlessness yes so I think
sometimes we don't tell that full story
people may not get it it's alright to
have some fears and some insecurities as
you're going through it but you have to
push through that wall it's almost like
if there isn't a little bit of fear yeah
then you can't be fearless if you were
starting from scratch from the beginning
of your career and trying to build the
career that you have today where would
you begin well well the real answer and
not the I guess successful role model
entrepreneur Ian soar like the answer
you get from your teachers is I would
probably be scared to death you know
this
you know this generation is probably one
of the most empowered generations of our
you know ever the most entrepreneurial
generation and I would say this
generation is also the generation who
like the world and since its kind of
turned its back on because it's not
protecting their future whether it's
from a from a a world point of view or
from a personal point of view or even
from a a point of view of what their
future is going to be like but this
global warming or whether it's even how
they're going to have a job or career so
that first was scared me then number two
it was scared me and make me angry that
that it was like that for me number two
would be that you know I also would be
kind of intimidated by the competition
because everybody's trying to be it the
next Steve Jobs the next Martin Scorsese
the next Puff Daddy
nights jay-z or so on and I'm saying
right so there's so much competition but
when I started there was nobody really
trying to do what I was doing and so I
think that it's very important to know
the reality so my advice to future
entrepreneurs is to always know the
reality know what you're getting
yourself into know how hard it's going
to be how competitive is going to be
even with that being said I think
there's more chance today than ever to
get seen and heard to get noticed and I
think that we're at a time where the
people that really really work hard and
really really believing they cells and
really really don't give up on your
dreams no matter how many times they
fall down or the ones that's going to be
successful is there anything you would
not promote they didn't how about I got
Diddy dog food no I wouldn't do bidi dog
food I would I don't know make your dog
yep - a rap or something I wouldn't do
did it you wouldn't do dog food I mean I
would do was organic for me like I
of candles I would do candles I love
jewelry I would do jewelry that that
fits I would do hotels it you know
whatever it was in the realm of
entertainment or lifestyle a curator of
cool you know that's what I do it's one
of my favorite quotes I came up with it
with my uncle had an uncle named uncle
shrimp and it uncle shrimp is a short
kind of guy you know lost his hair I
like the age 20 so his bald-headed and
he was just so charismatic and he told
me this after I injured myself and I
realized that I wasn't going to be a
football player and and he told me you
know they never lose sight of your
dreams but he also told me this as who I
was he knew that now was going to be a
turning point I'd I could have turned to
the streets and followed in the
footsteps of my father or I could dream
the impossible dream right and he also
wanted me to notice as an
african-american man because you know
that fear of having a dream and that
fear of oh I can't dream that that you
know I can't never be able to do that
right you know it was important to know
that yes you can have that dream but you
have to know honestly what it's going to
take for you to achieve that dream and
so then I came up with a quote and it
goes for everybody all genders all races
you know don't be afraid to close your
eyes and dream but then you have to open
your eyes and see the reality of what
it's going to take for you to achieve
that dream and a lot of people they kind
of see whether it's musicians or
athletes or entertainers or even just
successful people but they don't
understand the the thing that it takes
for them to get to the point that
they've got it and you know that's why
it's a very important quote to me and I
think it you know it has inspired people
and it inspires me every day thank you
guys so much for watching I made this
video because David newbie asked me to
so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I'd also love to know what your
Sean Combs is ten rules meant the most
to you leave it in the comments I'm
going to join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon